why do you think this can work when it's
never been used before the NFL because
it's never been used before then FL you
know I know chip did a version of what
he does but yeah it's a little one way
to find out you know it's never been
used nobody really knows what we're
gonna do all right what its gonna look
like and so we'll kind of take it one
game at a time I always like to keep
calm and just you know be myself and you
know trust the game plan trust myself
trust my teammates going into it and you
know go out there play my game and let
the chips fall within there
what to me one of the most fascinating
stories is week one approaches what will
that Arizona Cardinals offense look like
I don't know that I buy into the clip
Kingsbury logic that it's going to be
successful yeah because it's never been
done before there's plenty of things
that have never been done before for a
reason yeah
and the big concern is quarterback
health are you gonna take hits sure is
it going to be too predictable or the
defensive backs too good at this level
you can't just sit back there and it's
clear you're gonna pass all the time we
talked about that before you're gonna be
in shotgun
how you gonna establish a running game
right when you're in shotgun all the
time if you're gonna throw it all the
time that run versus past guessing game
is always such a critical part of the
pre snap Chester sure you take that away
when it's past the ball pass the ball
pass the ball and we'll see whether or
not that works against the NFL caliber
defenses it works at the college level
yeah because there's a fundamental
difference between college defenders and
Prout it's not even close plus the hours
you can study film and get ready for a
game all the different things the
defenses can do because of all those
things we talked about there's a 20 hour
rule in college defenses are very basic
okay hey and like Chip Kelly would not
be the guy I would be throwing out there
right now to make everybody feel good
about you know I often sign Oh Chip
Kelly got off to a good start in
Philadelphia but man did the the NFL
catch on to his offense in a hurry and
the one thing that's a little different
than Chip Kelly from Kliff Kingsbury
okay because Chip Kelly you can throw
Steve Spurrier in this conversation for
guys who kind of did the same kind of
thing went from college geniuses to a
degree and now we're going to the NFL
Chip Kelly ran the football at least at
Oregon but here's
I uh I like Kliff Kingsbury yes
nobody ever considered him a college
genius no I that's what's that's what's
that's with astounding
there's no doubt about it I mean again I
almost throw it in the Matt Lafleur
category where I go Kliff Kingsbury is
certainly capable of being an NFL head
coach I just wish he would have been an
offensive coordinator in a few other
places first like I wish you to the head
coach four or five years from now but
either way get off for the job he's got
to go with it but yes I'm with you the
offense okay
hey we've never seen it in the NFL
before okay I mean I don't know I've
watched a lot of Texas Tech film I don't
think there's any schemes in their
offense in general where like NFL
coaches are gonna pick whoa we've never
seen this before how do we defend it
what do we do you know I don't know then
there's the running aspect of it like
you've mentioned where there is no
aspect of it where there's nothing to
sit here as an evaluator and go oh I
like this little element he brings to
the run game and then the play-action
pass of it so it's a total unknown and
you know Kliff Kingsbury hasn't been
around a lot of different offensive
minds and I just questioned the overall
inventory of the offense and let's face
it that Texas Tech film specifically as
it related to Patrick mahomes was one of
the reasons why he wasn't regarded as
the can't-miss surefire top of the stack
number one overall draft pick in 2017
because the film showed flaws that Kliff
Kingsbury did not eradicate from Patrick
mahomes game that have been eradicated
from his game by Andy Reid so you know
how much did he do with the talent that
he had I think that's another fair
question how much can he do with caliber
there's another comment that came very
made about calimary not being inclined
to tell him he doesn't like a play
polymer at this point will do whatever
the coach says he likes all the plays
he'll run all the plays he may feel
differently once he sees which plays
work and which plays just implode yep no
III mean I think so there's got to be a
little dialog there and I know Kyle
Emery cred has tried to say at the end
of that quote you're talking about like
hey I told them there was something I
didn't like yesterday but I mean he's a
young quarterback he's he's just trying
to give the head coach confidence he
wants to be a pleasure oh I like
everything coach I like it all there'll
be more dialogue as they continue but I
am truly intrigued not only to watch
Kyle Emery because I think he's gonna be
special and fun to watch and they're
gonna
wide open so that would be cool but I
don't know if he has enough support
around him or there's enough support and
talent on the offense for Kingsbury's
offensive work totally altogether and
yes I'm going to questioned it until I
see different big 12 defenses stink okay
you know even blinken Riley can say what
he wants they stink and the NFL Draft
shows that okay there's not a lot of NFL
talent the schemes aren't very complex
this is a different ballgame and it's
definitely I got to see it to believe it
situation yeah and look Oliver is
eventually going to encounter adversity
we talked about this with the Browns
with Murray he's never had any atrocity
in football he's gonna be facing it very
soon
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports